I wish Anna was with us here today
physically with us here today she's been
diagnosed with stage four adrenal
carcinoma first of all how is she doing
today
um she's actually doing pretty good
she's had for someone that has stage
four cancer
um my husband just lost his cousin to
stay for renal cancer
um and I kid it everybody's cancer is
different and stuff I'm hearing my chemo
treatment for Anna she store she's still
able to draw for herself she's still
able to take the kids to and from places
she got no hair she doesn't have
eyebrows
um she doesn't have any hair on her arms
I mean she's had like four cancer
treatments but she will not have any
more chemo treatments but I will say
like a lot of people thought that it was
going to make her sick and stuff down
and stuff I mean like it does wear her
body down sometimes but like
um
right and that now now what she does now
we the one thing that we have noticed
since we actually found out and since
she's been having chemo is like you know
sure go to like dinner into like Walmart
and she's very tired but like outside of
that be honest with you no because like
she had the four chemo treatments and we
just went to the doctor last week for
like her thing and now she only has to
go every three months to do scans and
the next course if she chooses to if
that time comes will be immuno immune
therapy or clinical trial miles and she
just wants to see how it's going to go
and we're going to we don't know what to
expect because the cancer is very
aggressive and it grew from nothing
to something huge on although on the
left side of her body really fast so I
guess for uh for me as her mother and I
know for her it's just scared not
knowing what is going to happen next now
when the chemo's starting to come out of
her body so do you know what her
prognosis is oh yeah we do know that we
don't say one day at a time you just say
one day at a time yeah okay oh no you no
we don't really know her prognosis well
we don't we don't we I mean we know that
you know it could be terminals we know
it's terminal but like we just like when
people ask that we just say because the
doctor said you know because she went
from like 10 to 5 to 1 and like you know
so I just tell people because I'm like
okay she's stage four she's not going to
go into remission we've all accepted
that
um so what I just tell people like one
day at a time like because you never
know because somebody can tell you six
months and you live five years I was I
was just gonna say I mean I if there's
anything we know about your family is
that you guys are resilient and you're
Fighters right honestly who's not to say
a year from now they don't have a cure
you know I mean I'm not trying to be me
but like that's optimistic the medical
field is growing every single day
there's always something like think
about how quick they come out with a
covered vaccine things like that like
I truly believe that eventually there
will be a cure for some kind of cancer
okay well that's that's I'm optimistic
yeah
so I I'm thrilled to hear that she's
doing okay all things considered that
she can go to Walmart and she can you
know go to yeah
full-time job yeah but I'm thinking of
her kids too right are they aware of
what's going on very the 10 year old is
aware
I don't think she fully understands
right you know what I mean what does she
understand that I think she understands
that Mommy is sick and Mommy might not
be here mommy may not be here for a
while so like Kailyn was always like
close with Anna but like now she's like
this yeah like she doesn't leave she
doesn't go anywhere without Anna and I
get that because she's thinking she goes
somewhere then maybe Anna might not be
at the house when she comes back
so they've had some of those tougher
conversations yeah because she's a lot
she's 10 but a lot more sure a lot more
mature than that I mean because around
older people Kylie I think she's too
young to even realize yeah because she
just knows mama's sick all the time Mama
sick that's all she knows and Judy fuss
is when they're sick and they get around
Mama yeah that's as the caretakers you
guys have really stepped up from what I
understand how are you guys doing
um I just I mean I want to show you all
the time like for me it's like an
emotional rollercoaster sometimes and
like mentally because it's always on my
mind like it's always right and for me
they like oh we'll stop talking about
for me it just helps talking about it
because like me keeping it in is just
like is eating me up in sides I mean it
is crazy to think like that she will not
be here probably in five years but I'm
hoping like you know I'm hoping that she
can pull through and fight 10 20 years
you know right but like if she doesn't
it is crazy to think like
but also just not her sister I tell
people that's also they share the same
birthday my oldest my youngest you're
the same birthday so yeah I know they
don't and you know I loved Alana when
you posted on your Instagram story
something to the effect of
you need to be nice to people because
you never know what people are going on
behind closed doors why did you feel
compelled to post that because not just
an Anna's case but in our case too like
we have like even though that we're on
TV every day and we got this big happy
life on TV and people are like oh girl
you got that money you're on TV
and they think just because you're
famous you have the best life ever no
and it's like but I still have real
that goes on behind closed doors and
people online only get to see an hour
entire lives or or whatever we allow
them to see on social media and they can
judge you off of an hour episode you
know what I mean like you didn't know
what happened during that episode behind
the scenes of that episode in the
process of us filming it or like now
we're all sitting here but like okay
you're not here with us going to Anna's
treatments we had no idea what animal
was dealing with right because we don't
realize is back in August
and stuff like that I was like why don't
you have any hair
why are people still hating like at this
point live your own life and just worry
about what you got to do tomorrow and
leave me alone worry about what bills
you gotta pay right but like I try to
tell the girls this we've been on TV
October 12 2011 which is Jessica's
birthday we started filming this whole
thing with Toddlers and Tiaras and
people have grown with Alana and with
pumpkin with Jessica even Anna even
Gigi's baby Caitlyn throughout the
year's team Bentley and all this I said
so really people have grown up with
y'all and grown through us and went from
UPS Downs highs lows in between and
loving through it all and so they just
assumed that they know and that's the
reason why that I kind of go and do like
the tick tock live watch parties the
hour before the show and during the show
and after well I think a lot of people
watch us I feel like they are owed an
entitlement yes yeah that they're
entitled to what's going on in your life
assuming there is going to be another
season will we find out more about
Anna's life it just depends because our
life is still rolling without the
cameras rolling there's no cameras
that's your cameras he doesn't just
pause on the cameras
right yeah because because
in season six in season six she had hair
and I know longer has here she lost that
two weeks after yeah what do you think
it was that made her more comfortable
with saying I will be on the show this
season
I think sharing her story being a part
of Mama's story too like right we all
knew that when we had talked about it
that you know Anna was gonna go and then
what we were gonna go so then it would
be like all of us basically reuniting
together yeah and at that point like I
don't think anybody cared about the
cameras being there do you talk to her
about you know whether she'd want to
share what she's going through on TV
yeah but we let her do that on her
timing like when people come to our Tick
Tock Pages or our Instagram pages and
always ask us like hey could we you know
um buy something because she has had
people be very generous to her right
over this process and stuff
um but we just don't tell any of her
business medical business because it's
not our story to tell if she wants to
tell it then she's right she can tell us
and so what we do is we have turns yeah
that's what happens we allow artists to
come forward with it and then because
it's a lot of process so like when she
goes to doctor's appointments and stuff
like that she's very transparent with
social media as well like when she does
have appointments and things like that
and sometimes if she didn't get all that
great news you can kind of tell them
live and stuff like that she she doesn't
really want to tell everybody yet so I'm
just like Anna you don't have you don't
owe anybody anything right this is yours